let's start with the universe do you
ever think of the universe as a kind of
machine that designs beautiful things at
multiple scales
I I do
um and I think of nature in that way in
general
in the context of design specifically
I think of nature as everything that
isn't and tropical Mass everything that
is not produced by humankind
the birds and the rocks and everything
in between fungi elephants whales do you
think there's an intricate ways in which
there's a connection between humans and
nature yes and we're looking for it
I think that from let's say from the
beginning of mankind uh going back 200
000 years the products that we have
designed have separated us from nature
and it's ironic that the things that we
designed and produced as humankind those
are exactly the things that separated us
before that we were we were totally in
complete completely connected
and I want to return to that world but
bring the tools of engineering and
computation to it yes yes I absolutely
believe that there is so much to Nature
that that we still have not leveraged
and we still have not understood and we
still haven't and so much of our work is
designed but a lot of it is science is
unveiling and
um and and finding new truths about the
natural world that we were not aware
before everybody talks about
intelligence these days but I like to
think that nature has
kind of wisdom that exists Beyond
intelligence or above intelligence and
it's that wisdom that we're trying to
tap into through technology if you think
about humans versus nature at least in
the realm at least in the context of
definition of
nature is everything but
um anthropo mass and I'm using on Milo
who is an incredible
Professor from The weissmann Institute
who came up with this definition of
entropomas in 2020
when he identified that 2020 was the
crossover year when anthropomas exceeded
biomass on the planet so all of the
design Goods that we have created and
brought into the world now outweigh all
of the biomass
including of course all Plastics and
wearables building cities but also
asphalt and concrete all outweigh the
scale of the biomass and actually that
was a moment you know how in life there
are moments that be a handful of moments
that get you to
course correct and and my it was a zoom
conversation with Ron and that was a
moment for me
um when I realized that that imbalance
now we've superseded the biomass on the
planet where do we go from here
and you've heard the expression more
more phones than bones and the
anthropomas and the anthropocene
um and and the technosphere sort of
outweighing the biosphere
um but now we are really trying to look
at is is there a way
in which all things technosphere are
designed as if as if they are part of
the biosphere meaning if you could today
grow instead of build everything and
anything if you could grow an iPhone if
you could grow a car
what would that world look like where
the touring test for sort of this this
kind of I call this material ecology
approach but this this notion that
everything material everything that you
design in the physical universe
can be read
and written to as or thought of or
perceived of as nature grown that's sort
of the touring test for for the company
or at least that's how I started I
thought well grow everything that's sort
of the slogan let's grow everything
and if we grow everything is there a
world in which driving a car is better
for nature than a world in which there
are no cars is there is it possible that
a world in which you build buildings in
cities that those buildings and cities
actually augment and heal nature as
opposed to their absence is there a
world in which we now go back to that
kind of synergy between nature and
humans where you cannot separate between
grown and made and it doesn't even
matter
is there a good term for the
intersection between biomass and
entrepromax like things that are grown
yeah so in 2005 I I called this material
ecology I thought what if all material
all things materials would be considered
part of the ecology and would have an
impact a positive impact on the ecology
um where we work together to help each
other all things nature all things human
and again you can say that that wisdom
in nature exists in fungi many mushroom
lovers always contest my thesis here and
saying well we have the mushroom Network
and we have the mother trees and they're
all connected and and why don't we just
simply hack into into mushrooms well
first of all yes they're connected but
that Network stops when there is a
physical Gap that Network
does not necessarily enable the the
whales in the in the Dominican to
connect with an olive tree in Israel to
connect with a weeping willow in Montana
and that's sort of a world that that I'm
dreaming about what what does it mean
for nature to have access
to the cloud at the kind of bandwidth
that we're talking about sort of think
neuralink for nature you know since the
um first computer uh the um and you know
this by heart probably better than I do
but we're both MIT lifers
um we today have computational power
that is
um one trillion times the power that we
had in in those times we have
26.5 trillion times the bandwidth
and
11.5 quintillion
times the memory which is incredible so
humankind since the since the first
computer has
approach and accessed such incredible
bandwidth
and we're asking what if nature had that
bandwidth so beyond genes and evolution
if there was a way to augment nature and
allow it access to the world of bits
what does nature look like now
and can nature
make decisions for herself as opposed to
being guided and guarded and abused by
by humankind so Nature has this inherent
wisdom that you spoke to but you're also
referring to augmenting that inherent
wisdom with something like a large
language model exactly so compress human
knowledge but also maintain whatever is
that intricate wisdom that allows plants
bacteria fungi to grow incredible things
at arbitrary scales adapting to whatever
environment and just surviving and
thriving no matter where no matter how
exactly so I think of it as large
molecule models and those large molecule
models of course large language models
are based on the on on Google and search
engines and and so on and so forth and
we don't have this data currently and
part of our mission is is to do just
that trying to uh quantify and
understand
um the language that exists across all
Kingdoms of Life across all five
kingdoms of life
and if we can understand that language
is there a way for us to First make
sense of it find logic in it and then
generate certain computational tools
that Empower nature to to build better
crops to to increase the level of
biodiversity in in the company we're
constantly asking what does nature want
like what what does nature want from a
compute view if it knew it what what
could Aid it and whatever the heck it's
wanting to do yeah so we keep coming
back to this this answer of nature wants
to increase
information
but decrease entropy right so find order
but constantly increase the information
scale and and this is true for what our
work also tries to do because we're
constantly trying to
fight against the dimensional mismatch
between things made and things grown
right and and as designers we are
educated to think in X Y and Z and
that's pretty much where architectural
education ends and biological education
begins so in reducing that dimensional
mismatch we're missing out on
opportunities to create things made as
if grown but in the natural environment
we're asking can we provide nature with
these extra dimensions and again I I'm
not sure what nature wants but I'm
curious as to what happens when you
provide these tools to the Natural
environments obviously with
responsibility obviously with control
obviously with ethics and and moral code
um but is there a world in which nature
can help fix itself uh using those tools
and by the way we're talking about a
company called oxman yeah I'll just just
a few words about the team yeah what
kind of humans work at a place like this
that are trying to figure out what
nature wants you know I think they're
first like you they're they're humanists
first
um they come from different disciplines
and different disciplinary backgrounds
and just as an example we have a
brilliant designer who is just a
mathematical genius and a computer
scientist and a mechanical engineer who
is trained
um as a synthetic biologist and
um and now we're hiring a microbiologist
and a chemist
architects of course and designers uh
roboticist so it's really it's Noah's
Ark right two of each and always dancing
between this line of the artificial the
synthetic and the and the real what's
the term for and the natural yeah the
built in the grown nature and culture
technology and biology but we're we're
constantly seeking to to ask how can we
build design and deploy products in
three scales the molecular scale which I
briefly hinted to
um and their and the molecular scale
we're really looking to understand
whether there is a universal language to
Nature and what that language is and
then build build a tool that
um I think and dream of it is the iPhone
for nature if nature had an iPhone
um what would that iPhone look like does
that mean creating an interface
between nature and the computational
tools we have exactly it goes back to
that 11.5 quintillion times the
bandwidth that that humans have have
have now arrived at and and giving that
to Nature and seeing what you know what
what happens there can animals actually
use this
interface to know that they need to run
away from fire can plants use this
interface to increase the rate of
photosynthesis in the presence of a
smoke cloud can they do this
quote-unquote automatically without a
kind of a top-down Brute Force policy
based method that's authored and
deployed by humans and so this work
really relates to that interface with
the natural world and then there's a
second area in the company which focuses
on growing products
and here we're focusing on a single
product that starts from CO2
um it becomes a product it's consumed
it's used it's worn by a human and then
it
um goes back to the soil and it grows an
edible fruit plant so we're talking
about from CO2 to fruit yeah it starts
from CO2 and it ends with something that
you can like literally eat
um so so the world's first entirely
biodegradable bi-compatible by renewable
product that's grown yes either using
plant matter or using bacteria but we
are really looking at um carbon
recycling technologies that start with
methane or Wastewater
um and end with this wonderful
Reincarnation of a an a thing that
doesn't need to end up in a composting
site but can just be thrown into the
ground and grow Olive and find peace and
there's a lot of textile based work out
there that is focused on one single
element in this long chain like oh let's
create
um you know leather out of mycelium or
or less create textile out of cellulose
but then it stops there and you get to
assembling the shoe or the wearable and
you and you you need a little bit of
glue and you need a little bit of this
material a little bit of that material
to to make it water resistant and then
it's over so that's one thing that we're
trying to solve for is how to create a
product that is materially
computationally robotically novel
um and goes through all of these phases
from the creation from this carbon
recycling technology to
um to the product to literally how do
you think about you know Reinventing an
industry that is focused on assembly and
putting things together and using humans
to do that can that you know can that
happen just using robots and microbes
and that's it and doing it end to end I
would love to see what this Factory
looks like and the factories is great
too I'm I'm very very excited in October
we'll we'll share first
um first Renditions of of some of this
working in February we'll we'll invite
you to the lab I'm there